hier sehen wir den
FDP-Chef und wenn nicht mehr schief geht
dann ist er auch bei der neue
Bundesfinanzminister vor wenigen Minuten
ist Christian Lindner im Axel Springer
Hochhaus in Berlin angekommen wo unsere
Studios sind und sagt so schnell kann's
gehen schon ist er hier im Studio und
das erste was er gerade gesagt hat Hallo
Herr Lindner Grüße Gewinne sind
steuerfrei wenn Sie also die
Millionengewinn schon mal der erste gute
Tipp disse wenn nichts mehr schief geht
Finanzministers
nicht verschickt hat das gerade gesagt
sind sie bald ist Finanzminister und
damit werden Sie zu einer wirklich
einflussreichsten Politik Europas ihr
Wort hat dann global Gewicht es ist ein
Gänsehautfeeling für Sie oder bereitet
ihnen schlafprobleme
ich habe da sehr großen Respekt sie
haben zurecht beschrieben dass es sehr
große Aufgaben sind es geht darum in
Deutschland Investitionen und viele
Vorhaben der neuen Koalition zu
ermöglichen auf der anderen Seite steht
in Europa im nächsten Jahr an dass wir
unseren Stabilitäts und Wachstumspakt
innerhalb der Währungsunion neu
vermessen gerade in Zeiten drohender
inflations Risiken ist das eine wichtige
Aufgabe ich bin erleichtert dass ich
diese Aufgaben nicht alleine schuld wäre
das Bundesministerium der Finanzen ist
ja ein hochqualifiziertes Ministerium
Energie
750 1000 Mitarbeiter die werden der Chef
von 50 Mitarbeitern wie viel hatten Sie
bisher so
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion
500 Leute man das zusammen nimmt aber
wie gesagt man stellt sie einer solchen
Fabian nicht allein sondern hat er
qualifizierte und erfahrene
Persönlichkeiten an der Seite und auf
die vertraue ich auch man könnte auch
sagen wer traut sich was ja ich habe
Respekt vor dieser Aufgabe aber man darf
die Verantwortung nicht scheuen wir sind
bei der Bundestagswahl ja beauftragt
worden den Status Quo in Deutschland zu
überwinden und Dinge zu ermöglichen wir
wollen ja investieren in die
Digitalisierung von Wirtschaft Staat und
Gesellschaft die haben das Ziel eine
klimaneutrale
Industrienation zu werden wir machen uns
auf den Weg die Breite Mitte der
Gesellschaft zu
entlasten beispielsweise indem wir die
sogenannte EEG-Umlage auf den Strompreis
ab 01.01 20-23 abschaffen und ich will
noch eine persönliche Mission die mir am
Herzen ist hinzufügen Herzen liegt
hinzufügen Sie wissen ich bin kein
Freund von Steuererhöhungen aber das
Steuerrecht dass wir haben
das müssen sich alle halten
Schwarzarbeit und Steuerhinterziehung
damit schädigt man die ehrlichen
Steuerzahler Rinnen und Steuerzahler und
deshalb will ich es mir insbesondere zur
Aufgabe machen dagegen vorzugehen ein
Beispiel ist dass ich vorgeschlagen habe
das gesetzlich untersagt wird das
Immobilien mit Bargeld gekauft werden
und wär z.b. hier in Berlin aus dem
Ausland zukünftig eine Immobilie kaufen
möchte wer muss nachweisen dass das mit
versteuertem Geld investiert Elena jetzt
sitzende ab 11 Uhr im Bundeskanzleramt
oder teilweise auch digital zu gestaltet
die Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten
mit noch Kanzlerin Angela Merkel und dem
bald Kanzler Olaf Scholz zusammen und
entscheiden über neue Corona Maßnahmen
das heißt so um 13 Uhr wenn sie vor die
Presse treten werden werden wir wieder
ein Stück Freiheit
weniger haben wie sehr bedrückt sieht
dass ich möchte mir diese
Bewertung nicht zu eigen machen es geht
ja genau darum jetzt in dieser sehr
schwierigen Situation der Pandemie die
richtige Balance aus dem notwendigen
Gesundheitsschutz einerseits zu finden
und andererseits soviel
gesellschaftliches Leben und Freiheit
wie möglich zu erhalten ich höre wohl
dass viele in diesen Tagen schon nach
einem Lockdown rufen und ich halte das
sicherlich für eine ultima ratio das
hatten wir ja auch schon erinnere nur
daran wie lange es nach dem November
Lockdown des vergangenen Jahres gedauert
hat bis wir wieder das gesellschaftliche
Leben öffnen konnten ein Lockdown mit
ihnen und deshalb müssen wir in der Tat
alles unternehmen damit sich das nicht
wiederholt die neue Strategie läuft
darauf hinaus dass wir durch impfen und
Boostern dafür gibt's jetzt einen neuen
Krisenstab an der Spitze ja einen
General dass er beim Impfen und Boostern
mehr Tempo machen dass wir gegen die
vierte Welle an impfen und an Boostern
und das wäre auf der anderen Seite
unsere packte beschränken aber nur
insoweit es wird nicht erforderlich ist
aber eben auch so konsequent wie es
nötig ist damit unser Gesundheitssystem
nicht dauerhaft überlastet wird und dann
soll es ja auch wohl möglich jetzt zur
impflicht kommen weil kannst Olaf Scholz
hat ja schon gesagt dass er dann mit
darauf mit Ja stimmen würde sie auch
noch liegen ja keine Anträge vor das
Verfahren sieht ja vor dass aus der
Mitte des Deutschen Bundestages ohne den
Fraktionszwang
Anträge gestellt und erarbeitet werden
und dass jeder seine eigene Abwägung
treffen kann ich halte das sage ich
Ihnen sofort ich halte dieses Verfahren
auch für wichtig denn alle von Frau
Merkel bis zu Herrn Scholz von den
Grünen bis zur FDP haben ja
ausgeschlossen dass es zu einer
Impfpflicht kommen würde und wenn jetzt
einer Neubewertung vorgenommen werden
sie soll ich auch sagt ja die FDP wenn
eine Neubewertung vorgenommen soll dann
sollte das in einer offenen Debatte Pass
dann weil das den Menschen auch zeigt
das wird nicht gerungen wird und das ist
nicht die Entscheidung nur einer
Regierung ist und dann in der Breite des
Parlaments meine erinnerungen haben wie
wir ja ich kenne die Gruppen Anträge
noch im Einzelnen ja nicht aber ich sage
offen dass meine Richtung auch wie einer
Impfpflicht ist warum ich hatte gehofft
dass wir jetzt im Winter schon 1 in
Quote von
85% hätten ich bin enttäuscht dass die
Impfbereitschaft so gering ist der
kommen deshalb immer wieder in diese
Situationen wie jetzt wo Freiheiten für
alle eingeschränkt werden müssen
inzwischen gibt es auch Erfahrung mit
den vorhandenen Impfstoffen und deshalb
meine ich jetzt in der Abwägung wir
müssen uns öffnen für eine solche
Impfpflicht sein scharfes Schwert aber
ich glaube es ist Verhältnis aber Herr
Lindner ist natürlich gerade für die FDP
eine dramatische Kehrtwende Otto Schily
jeder ehemalige SPD Innenminister hat
gerade in einem Welt Interview gesagt es
sei eine Impfpflicht ist eine
verfassungswidrige Anmaßung des Staates
in einer freiheitlich rechtsstaatlichen
Demokratie darf sich der Staat nicht
anmaßen im einzelnen Menschen eine
bestimmte ärztliche Behandlung
aufzuzwingen das hätte auch so in ihrem
Wahlprogramm stehen können dem nein
diesen Worten nicht denn
der
geschätzte Otto Schily übersieht
möglicherweise dass wir ja bereits im
Pflichten haben bei Masern und Pocken
hat der Staat im Pflichten ausgesprochen
ohne dass das zu verfassungsrechtlichen
Bedenken geführt hätte also für mache
ich mir diese Argumentation nicht zu
eigen es gibt in meiner Partei und
meiner Fraktion auch andere Abwägungen
das will ich sehr klar sagen insofern
ist keine dramatische Wende wie sie
gesagt haben der FDP sondern sie haben
ja mich als Person gefragt und nicht als
Person komme jetzt zu einer anderen
Abwägung in der Tendenz ich kenne ja die
Gruppen Anträge im Einzel noch ich aber
in der Tendenz weil die Impfbereitschaft
geringer ist als gedacht weil die impf
Durchbrüche häufiger auftreten als
befürchtet und weil wir uns aus dieser
Situation fortwährend während dieser
Wellen das gesellschaftliche Leben in
Frage stellen zu müssen endlich befreien
müssen wir das auch so gelaufen wenn es
nicht diesen ich sag mal Trick oder
Umweg gegeben hätte das eben die
Abgeordneten selber diesen Antrag
einbringen und dann frei abstimmen
können hätten sie auch mitgemacht wenn
es ein Vorschlag der Ampelkoalition
gewesen wäre das war ja gerade einen
Verfahrensvorschlag des designierten
Justizministers Marco Buschmann von der
FDP und
dahinter steckt jetzt nichts eine Frage
der Ampelkoalition sondern dahinter
steht eine andere Abwägung das eine
Frage um dir in der Gesellschaft sehr
gerungen wird es ist eine Frage wo alle
staatstragenden Parteien ihre Positionen
jetzt in Frage gestellt haben und viele
Persönlichkeiten ihr eigene Abwägung
korrigieren und damit die Menschen sehen
das wirklich über diese Frage gerungen
wird das die Gegenargumente vorgetragen
werden dass die Argumente dafür im
Parlament präsentiert werden dass das in
einem Meinung Vergleich kommt und das
aus der Mitte des Parlaments die
Position wirklich erarbeitet und nicht
vorgegeben wird das ist ja auch ein
wichtiger Beitrag zur Versöhnung der
Gesellschaft und um die
unterschiedlichen Auffassungen
zusammenzubringen und deshalb ist dieses
Verfahren zur Befriedung eines großen
Konfliktes Weise Stichwort Versöhnung
der Gesellschaft nun wird heute auch die
Zweig Regel beschlossen werden das ist
eben keine Versöhnung der geimpften und
der ungeimpften sondern die ungeimpften
werden ausgeschlossen das ist das eine
das andere ist das Nest wie viele
Kleinbetriebe auch wieder betroffen sein
werden wenn Restaurants Kinos naja
Restaurants nicht Kinos Theater und so
weiter wieder schließen müssen wie
wollen Sie da helfen auch als
Bundesfinanzminister wie wollen sie voll
und zwar finanziell will die ersten Teil
ihrer Frage noch aufnehmen die 2G Regeln
sind leider erforderlich weil wir beim
Impfen noch nicht so weit sind wie wir
sein müssten zum einen haben wir bei den
Booster Impfungen nicht den Fortschritt
den wir logistisch bräuchten wir jetzt
nicht zurückschauen
die Bundesregierung von Frau Merkel
scheidet ja aus dem Abend aber da haben
wir eine Hypothek übernommen bei dem
Mangel Denim Fortschritt und die
Impfbereitschaft ist zu bringen und wir
wissen dass ungeimpfte Menschen sich
gegenwärtig sehr häufig infizieren und
bedroht sind von schwerem
Krankheitsverlauf sehen Sie diese zwei
Regel Zweig Regel also auch bitte als
Schutzmaßnahme gegenüber den ungeimpften
die im gesellschaftlichen Leben größere
Gefährdungen haben als die durch Impfung
geschützten und zum anderen wenn es
jetzt zu
Einschränkungen des wirtschaftlichen
Lebens kommt etwa aufgrund der Zweig
Regeln im dann wird selbstverständlich
zu prüfen sein ob und mit welchen
Mitteln auch die staatliche
Verantwortungsgemeinschaft hilft dazu
ist aber zur Stunde gewissermaßen
amtlich noch nichts konkret Anzug
könnten sie genug Geld in der Kasse ja
unser Staat ist unverändert sehr
finanziell leistungsfähig genug
ja dann waren wir
kommen da ist eine Spirale das
Preissteigerung und Lohnerhöhung zu
Preissteigerungen zur Lohnerhöhung für
das sehr schwer zu unterbrechen und ich
bin deshalb dankbar über die die
Vereinbarung der Tarifparteien im
öffentlichen Dienst die haben
Arbeitgeber und die Gewerkschaften sehr
klug agiert haben einen maßvollen
Tarifabschluss gemacht damit diese
Spirale nicht in Gang kommt dann haben
wir sehr gute Aussicht dass es im
nächsten Jahr zu einer Normalisierung
bei der Preisentwicklung kommt aber
Aufmerksamkeit ist nötig und der Staat
darf Preise nicht weiter treiben sondern
wir sollten an Entlastung arbeiten Spar
hier etwa schon über die EEG Umlage beim
Strom noch mal Stichwort Geld und auch
im Zusammenhange mit Corona figlio
Betriebe klagen jetzt und sagen in
dieser Situation auch noch den
Mindestlohn auf 12 € anzuheben das
können wir einfach nicht stemmen ist es
eine Option die L&S ist lones zu
verschieben nein das ist verabredet das
kommt es ist auch keine ungebührliche
nicht tragbare Belastung in Deutschland
sondern das kann unsere Wirtschaft und
der Mann muss ja sehen das sagte gerade
schon die Umlage aus den erneuerbaren
Energien auf den Strompreis entfällt
auch bei den mittelständischen Betrieben
und in der Gastronomie haben wir ja
einen reduzierten Mehrwertsteuersatz den
wir fort schreiben wollen das heißt er
auch dort gibt es durch den steigenden
Mindestlohn auf der anderen Seite auch
eine Entlastung für die Betriebe das in
dem Paket zusammengenommen zeigt das ist
eine wirtschaftlich ausgewogene Politik
in 1 Punkte der im Zusammenhang mit
Coronavirus wichtig ist und da hätte ich
auch noch gerne eine klare Aussage von
ihnen dazu Lindner es geht darum wie
lange die
Impfschutz wie lange der Impfschutz
gültig sein soll sozusagen ab wann man
als nicht mehr
nicht geimpft Geld sechs Monate oder
neun Monate und das ist ein Gespräch
auch das hat Olaf Scholz angesprochen
ihre klare Meinung sechs Monate oder
neun Monate ab wann muss man sozusagen
wieder zum Impfen TÜV dazu kann ich
keine politische Einschätzung geben weil
wir uns hier auf den Rat von
Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern verlassen müssen ich
bin kein Virologe und deshalb will ich
jetzt auch keine Zahl in den Raum
stellen was angemessen ist die
Entscheidung muss getroffen werden auf
der Basis wissenschaftlichen rad
bedeutet aber auf jeden Fall ja das
gepostet werden muss was das Zeug hält
und zwar nicht nur jetzt aktuell sondern
auch weiter so ist die Vorgabe das bis
Weihnachten noch 30 Millionen Menschen
in Deutschland nachgeimpft werden soll
das sind noch 22 Tage die wir da haben
das würde und knapp 1,5 Millionen 1,3
sie sind der Finanzexperte pro Tag
bedeuten dass er scheint aussichtslos
selbst wenn ein General jetzt mitmacht
wie soll das funktionieren wir müssen so
viel davon erreichen wie möglich und
deshalb der dringender Appell an die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer die
Möglichkeit eine Auffrischungsimpfung zu
nutzen und wenn sie noch nicht geimpft
sind sich impfen zu lassen auch eine
Erstimpfung ist bereits ein
gesundheitlicher Schutz jetzt ist
wirklich der Aller späteste Zeitpunkt
gekommen sich um eine Impfung zu bemühen
die Angebote müssen ausgeweitet werden
das ist völlig klar zeigt sich im
Nachhinein dass es auch ein Fehler war
dass viele öffentliche Impfzentren
bereits runtergefahren wurden oder gar
geschlossen worden das muss jetzt
aufgeholt werden wenn es jemand kann
dann ein solcher Krisenstab auch mit
militärischer Logistik Erfahrung und ich
habe schon gesagt all diejenigen die
medizinisch verantwortbar eine Impfung
verabreichen können sollten das tun
beispielsweise auch in Apotheken sollte
das erfolgen Elena ein weiteres Thema
dem Amtsantritt eben über den
Dieselkraftstoff der sich durch die
geplante Angleichung der Steuersätze für
Diesel und Benzin massiv verteuern würde
der künftige Verkehrsminister also ihr
Generalsekretär Volker Wissing will
Dieselfahrer dafür an anderer Stelle
entlasten die Grünen lehnen das empört
ab müssen Dieselfahrer also jetzt Angst
vor der Ampel haben
würde uns Vertrag liest stellt fest dass
dort keine Steuer Erhöhung für die
Besitzer von Dieselfahrzeugen geplant
ist und das Recht nicht diejenigen die
heute ein Dieselfahrzeug haben müssen
sich Sorgen dass sie in Zukunft ihren
Alltag mit ihrem Auto als Pendler oder
Pendler nicht bestreiten können
sie haben sehr diskret und sehr
harmonisch verhandelt so hat es
jedenfalls nach außen hin diskret stimmt
harmonisch würde ich etwas anders
beschreiben sind jedenfalls harmonisch
nach außen hin aufgetreten können wir
damit rechnen dass das so bleibt wird
auch angesichts wieder Sie Chancen auf
die Uhr ich weiß sie müssen gleich los
sie haben Fraktionssitzung Wer entlassen
sie auch gleich aber können wir davon
ausgehen dass das tatsächlich so
weitergeht oder werden sie sich dann
doch früher oder später auch wieder
zerspanen zerspanen also natürlich gibt
es Bewertungsunterschiede in der Politik
es ist ja eine Koalition und keine
Fusion von SPD Grünen und FDP und jeder
weiß dass die politischen Unterschiede
zwischen der FDP einerseits und SPD und
Grünen andererseits vor der Wahl groß
waren und diese Unterschiede sind ja
nicht verschwunden da ganz
unterschiedlich Herangehensweisen an die
Themen sie wissen wir setzen stark auf
die Selbstbestimmung der Menschen auf
die Marktwirtschaft aus anderen Pflicht
andere ja werden auch eine Gurtpflicht
im Auto also insofern die FDP ist nicht
gegen jede Pflicht aber wollen eben den
Raum für Selbstbestimmung so groß halten
wie möglich andere haben andere
Akzentsetzung und legt es natürlich dann
Bewertungsunterschiede
aber meine Erwartung ist dass wir mit
den Unterschieden in der Sache
seriös umgehen und uns um gemeinsame
Lösungen bemühen denn in dieser
Situation erwarten die Menschen doch für
eine Regierung dass sie Probleme aus dem
Weg schafft und nicht selbst zu einem
Problem wird weil sie sich gegenseitig
blockieren letzte Frage erlinda sie
treten in große Fußstapfen in diesem
großen
Ministerium Karl Schiller Helmut Schmidt
Wolfgang Schäuble Olaf Scholz nicht zu
vergessen wer von denen wäre ihr Vorbild
jede Zeit hat die Herausforderungen und
man kann die Situation mit der Wolfgang
Schäuble umzugehen hatte oder Olaf
Scholz umzugehen hatte nicht mit dem
vergleichen was jetzt vor uns liegt und
deshalb muss man sich um einen eigenen
Akzent bemühen aber sie haben Recht ist
ein sehr traditionsreiches sehr
bedeutsames Haus und deshalb gehe ich
auch mit einer Demut an die Aufgaben
heran ganz herzlichen Dank